[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend an diesem
ersten Mai Montag wo die Zahnes auch
dabei für den Sport sehr gerne schönen
guten Abend wir haben unter anderem
diese Themen für Sie
zwischen Protest und feiern am Tag der
Arbeit rufen Gewerkschaften zum Kampf
für Arbeitnehmerrechte auf mit neuem
Selbstbewusstsein
für 49 Euro quer durchs Land ab heute
geht das deutschlandticket zum Start
holpert es aber noch bei der
angekündigten nahverkehrsrevolution
und dänischer Sieg am Radsport Feiertag
der ein tagesklassiker Frankfurt
Eschborn verlangt den Profis mit neuer
Strecke alles ab
[Musik]
viele haben heute einfach den freien Tag
der Arbeit genossen andere fast
290.000 waren nach Gewerkschaftsangaben
auf Kundgebungen die Vorsitzende des
deutschen gewerkschaftsbunds fahimi
kündigt der harte Auseinandersetzungen
an aus reiner Einsicht bewege sich in
den Chefetagen gar nichts der
Bundeskanzler war für Respekt nicht nur
für Ingenieure und IT-
sie arbeiten auf dem Bau im Supermarkt
in der Pflege und demonstrieren an
diesem ersten Mai für gute Arbeit und
guten Lohn die Inflation habe ein Loch
in den Geldbeutel gebrannt ruft
DGB-Vorsitzende Jasmin vahimi in Köln
das beste Mittel gegen steigende
Lebenshaltungskosten sind eben kräftige
Lohn und Gehaltszuwächse die wir im
Zweifel auch per Streik erkämpfen werden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen weil eben
klatschen und warme Worte nicht reichen
wir wollen für hervorragende Arbeit auch
endlich anständig bezahlt werden
ungebrochen solidarisch lautet jetzt das
Motto des DGB zusammen sind wir stark
und in diesem Jahr besonders sagen sie
hier wir bekommen tatsächlich jetzt auch
und das merken wir auch vermehrt zu
laufen und ich glaube die Menschen
merken in dieser Situation dass sich
etwas verändern muss man sieht sie ja
bei Verdi die haben durch ihren Streik
fast 80.000 Mitglieder dazu geworden
auch der Bundeskanzler besucht heute
eine gewerkschaftskundgebung in Koblenz
Scholz appelliert ein Unternehmen sich
ein Tarifverträge zu halten und noch
etwas manche Betriebe suchen Händlerin
Fachkräfte
aber manche Betriebe bilden auch nicht
aus und deshalb hier und an dieser
Stelle der Appell es sollen sich alle
noch einmal zusammenreißen und alles
dafür tun dass die Zahl der
Ausbildungsplätze für Deutschland weiter
steigt ein Tag der Arbeit in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangels und die Menschen heute
auf der Straße fordern Jobs die es wert
sind
die Gewerkschaften treten dieses Jahr
durchaus selbstbewusst auf auch wegen
vergleichsweise hohe Tarifabschlüsse
aber die Zahl ihrer Mitglieder schwindet
seit Jahren kontinuierlich minus vier
Millionen seit 1994 der DGB hofft jetzt
auf eine Trendumkehr auch durch den
Arbeitskräftemangel der stärkt die
Position der Arbeitnehmer Umbruch als
Chance dazu Stefan Schlösser
das Unternehmen randstad ist Marktführer
unter den Personaldienstleistern in
Deutschland vermittelt rund 45.000
Arbeitskräfte pro Jahr deren Position
hat sich deutlich verbessert
die Möglichkeiten aller Arbeitnehmer
sind in den letzten Jahren stärker
geworden aufgrund der demografischen
Situation Deutschland ist ja das
zweitälteste Land durchschnittlich der
Erde haben wir einfach einen deutlichen
Arbeitskräfte und Fachkräftemangel und
das setzt uns die Arbeitnehmer natürlich
in eine gute Position
davon profitieren auch die
Gewerkschaften ob öffentlicher Dienst
bei der Bahn oder den Metallern mit
zahlreichen Streiks haben Mitarbeiter
und Mitarbeiterinnen verschiedener
Branchen hohe Abschlüsse durchgesetzt
davon profitieren für alle die unteren
Einkommensschichten daran kann man sehen
durch kollektives Handeln haben vor
allen Dingen die kleineren die
schwächeren die geringer qualifizierten
enorme Chancen ihre Position zu
verbessern und über Gewerkschaften auch
den sozialen Aufstieg wieder möglich zu
machen wollen die Gewerkschaften
Gestaltungsmacht bleiben müssen auch sie
sich ständig anpassen mahnt einer der
den DGB lange angeführt hat
das Arbeitsteam hat sich stark verändert
Demografie Transformation
Klimawandel alles Punkte die uns vor
völlig neu Herausforderungen stellen
aber wir können das schaffen
die Grundidee der Gewerkschaft dass man
gemeinsam stärker ist wenn man gemeinsam
steht als wenn man alleine verhandelt
die bleibt der Abgesang auf die
Gewerkschaften wurde schon oft
angestimmt sie müssen kämpfen doch zur
Zeit scheinen sie so stark wie lange
nicht
Arbeit Wertschätzung Bezahlung zur
aktuellen Situation haben wir online
Hintergründe und Interviews und eine
exklusive Umfrage jeder fünfte junge
Erwachsene will am liebsten kündigen die
Gründe dafür und mehr in unserer ZDF
heute App
in Frankreich ist dieser 1 Mai ein
besonderer denn die umstrittene
Rentenreform von Präsident macron
mobilisierte diesmal hunderttausende die
in vielen Städten ihrem Zorn Luft
machten es gab auch Zusammenstöße mit
der Polizei in Frankreich gibt es
inzwischen aber Zweifel ob die
Massenproteste gegen die Reform
weitergehen denn die Front der
Gewerkschaften bröckelt Thomas Walde
berichtet
Arbeiterlieder gehören wie hier in Nord
zum französischen ersten Mai und
Maiglöckchen auch doch in diesem Jahr
hat der Tag eine besondere Bedeutung für
die Gewerkschaften solle eine machtvolle
Demonstration werden gegen die
Rentenreform von Präsident macron obwohl
die vom Verfassungsgericht gebilligt und
unterzeichnet wurde
die Entschlossenheit der Beschäftigten
und der Gewerkschaften ist unverändert
den Rückzug der Reform zu erreichen das
zeigt die hohe Mobilisierung heute die
Beschäftigten weigern sich anderes zu
besprechen solange diese Reform nicht
zurückgezogen wird
die Gewerkschaften riefen gemeinsam zur
Demonstration die größte von ihnen die
CFDT sagt aber so seid ihre Form nicht
mehr zu stoppen und sie sei bereit
wieder mit der Regierung zu reden
wir müssen unsere Forderungen durch
Demonstrationen ausdrücken und in den
kommenden Tagen müssen unsere Forderung
auch gegenüber der Regierung zur Sprache
bringen ein Gewerkschafter muss mit
seinem Gegenüber reden
nachdem sich die Gewerkschaften zuletzt
Kollektiv geweigert hatten mit der
Regierung zu sprechen zeigen sich nun
also Risse es ist richtig dass eine
Gewerkschaft sie auf Kompromisse setzt
und Diskussionen anders als andere
Gewerkschaften die eine revolutionäre
Linie vertreten
die Regierung will alle nun zum Dialog
einladen wenn auch nicht mehr über die
Rentenreform unterdessen gehen in vielen
Städten die ersten Mai Demonstrationen
zu Ende ähnlich wie in anderen Jahren
mit gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen
Tränengas und Festnahmen
ab heute macht Deutschland zumindest
teilweise Schluss mit dem Tarif
Dschungel im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
seit Mitternacht gilt das
deutschlandticket für 49 € im Monat mehr
als 3 Millionen sind bereits verkauft
750.000 davon an Neukunden die bisher
keine Monatskarte hatten das Ticket geht
überall im Land in Regionalzügen u und
S-Bahnen Bussen und Straßenbahnen tabu
bleiben Fernbusse und Fernzüge über den
ersten Tag mit neuem Ticket
die Hafen Fähren in Hamburg sind wie
Busse auf dem Wasser und ab heute auch
mit drin im deutschlandticket der
Andrang fast so groß wie zu Zeiten des
neuen euro-tickets das hobelak auch am
Wetter wenngleich einige diese Aussicht
schon mit dem neuen Deutschland Abo
genossen wir sind viel unterwegs auch in
Deutschland und von daher können wir das
Ticket gut nutzen meine Eltern die
schon passt das überhaupt ins Budget
aber die Regierung ist ja immer
hinterher mit Bahnen mit Strecken mit
Zügen die müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen
Gas geben das deutschland-ticket gibt es
als Plastikkarte oder digital und bis
Jahresende noch in Papierform es geht
egal wo gekauft überall in Deutschland
regional unterschiedlich sind
Sonderregeln etwa für die Fahrrad oder
Hunde Mitnahme hier konnten sich die
Verkehrsminister nicht einigen der
öffentliche Nahverkehr über eine
unterschiedliche Bedeutung und auch
Wertschätzung erfahren über den Laufe
der Zeit und das ist aber auch normal
weil es gibt Stadtstaaten Bundesländer
die Situation ist eben unterschiedlich
regional unterschiedlich auch die
Zuzahlung bei Studierenden Schüler und
sozial Deutschland Tickets sollten
eigentlich einheitlich 19 € kosten diese
Anpassung läuft aber noch die
Arbeitgeber können sich auch beteiligen
und das Abo günstiger machen das ist
monatlich kündbar 49 Euro Ticket heißt
das deutschland-ticket übrigens auch
nicht mehr falls es doch mal teurer
werden sollte
solche Schiffe ist es allerdings nicht
gedacht aber zum hinfahren mit den Öffis
wenn wir heute Nachmittag ein Kreuzer
das Doc verlässt
der Tübinger Oberbürgermeister Boris
Palmer provoziert und polarisiert seit
Jahren jetzt zieht er nach heftigen
Reaktionen auf einen Auftritt am Freitag
überraschend Konsequenzen er werde eine
Auszeit und professionelle Hilfe in
Anspruch nehmen auch um seine Familie zu
schützen
Timer hatte auf einer
migrationskonferenz in Frankfurt einen
rassistischen Begriff verwendet danach
mit Nazi rausrufen konfrontiert sagte er
zur Menge das ist nichts anderes als der
Judenstern heute räumte der 50-Jährige
ein das sei falsch und völlig
unangemessen gewesen
besonders in Berlin gibt es am ersten
Mai wieder Kundgebungen linke Gruppen
vergangenes Jahr was weitgehend
friedlich diesmal befürchten die
Behörden könnte das anders sein einige
tausend Teilnehmer der sogenannten
revolutionären ersten Mai Demo ziehen
zur Stunde vom Stadtteil Neukölln nach
Berlin Kreuzberg vor Ort ist auch ein
Großaufgebot der Polizei
im Moment scheint es ganz friedlich
Stefanie gargosch warum ist die
Wachsamkeit dieses Jahr noch höher
nun hier hinter mir läuft gerade die
erste revolutionäre mai Demo
durchkreuzberg in der Tat ist es bisher
friedlich geblieben die Polizei hat
einen besonderes Augenmerk auf diese
Demonstration bei sich sehr
unterschiedliche Gruppen zusammengetan
haben einmal hat die Linke sehr stark um
die Krawallmacher aus der Silvesternacht
geworden nach dem Motto Silvester 2.0
und es läuft eine palästinensische
Organisation mit die im Vorfeld in den
letzten Wochen durch antisemitische
Aussprüche aufgefallen ist daher sind
die Auflagen hier für diese Demo sehr
sehr hoch und es sind 6.300 Polizisten
in Einsatz allein 2500 aus dem
Bundesgebiet und alle hoffen natürlich
dass jetzt die Nacht heute in Berlin
krawallfrei bleibt
danke schön live aus Berlin Stefanie
darüber
russland hat in der vergangenen Nacht
erneut Ziele in vielen Teilen der
Ukraine beschossen dabei wurden
mindestens 30 Menschen verletzt nach
ukrainischen Angaben konnten die meisten
Raketen abgefangen werden
unterdessen bereitet sich die
ukrainische Armee im Osten des Landes
auf ihre Offensive vor unsere Porter
daran Hassan zadeva in wulleda nahe der
Front
wir fahren zur Front bei wulleda hier
hat die russische Armee erhebliche
Verluste erlitten und auch eingeräumt
beim Versuch durchzubrechen in den Don
Bass jetzt könnte die Ukraine einen
Versuch wagen im Zuge der Großoffensive
reger Verkehr an schweren militärischem
Gerät Artillerie Gefechte gewinnt oft
wer den Nachschub besser organisiert
es sind ukrainische Positionen die
feuern die Ukraine ist der russischen
Artillerie hier eben würdig auch durch
die verstärkt gelieferten westlichen
Waffen
ich bin jetzt seit einem Jahr hier
damals hatten sie uns die ganze Zeit
beschossen und wir hatten ihn kaum etwas
entgegenzusetzen
aber in der letzten Zeit hat sich die
Situation geändert jetzt dank der
westlichen Unterstützung hat sich das
Blatt gedreht
die Soldaten sind in kleinen Quartieren
untergebracht mit Küche und Bad Raum für
eine Handvoll Kämpfer die zentral wird
auch die Munition gelagert damit ein
Treffer nicht den gesamten Bestand
vernichtet
wir alle hier haben uns an die
Explosionen gewöhnt einfach an alles was
über uns fliegt
wenn Du Dich ausruhst und hörst dass es
weit weg ist dann kannst du dich weiter
ausruhen
die Soldaten haben wochenlang hart um
das strategisch wichtige volley da
gekämpft bald könnte ihn auch noch die
Großoffensive bevorstehen
helfen in Afghanistan Ja oder Nein
darüber berät seit heute eine
UN-Konferenz ohne die Taliban in keinem
Land der Welt sind die Rechte der Frauen
so eingeschränkt wie unter den Taliban
keine Parkbesuche kein Studium mehr
Arbeitsverbot bei nicht
Regierungsorganisationen die Folge die
Geberländer zahlen weniger und das
Welternährungsprogramm der UN musste im
April die Zahl der Empfänger von 13 auf
4 Millionen Menschen senken aus
Afghanistan berichtet Katrin Eugendorf
es ist ein geheimes Treffen in einer
Wohnung in Kabul sie sind VertreterInnen
von sechs Frauengruppen die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben Laila zeigt
mir ein Video von ihrem letzten Protest
die Taliban haben sie gewaltsam
auseinander getrieben sie hat an diesem
Tag ihr Baby verloren
die Welt darf Afghanistans Frauen nicht
alleine lassen fordern Sie alle
es ist die Verantwortung der Vereinten
Nationen für die Frauen und
Menschenrechte einzutreten wenn sie
Büros in Afghanistan öffnen dann müssen
sie das kontrollieren und dafür arbeiten
soll die UN ihre Hilfe einstellen eine
Frage über die sie heftig diskutieren
einige fordern der Westen müssen so
Druck ausüben auf die Taliban
Freiheit und Essen zu haben hat den
gleichen Wert für Afghanistans Frauen
wenn wir essen haben aber keine Freiheit
dann ist das inakzeptabel
in einer Shopping Mall in Kabul treffen
wir Tabasco erst seit kurzem arbeitet
sie als Verkäuferin in einer Boutique
die 22-Jährige war vorher Journalistin
doch die Taliban haben ihren Sender
geschlossen
wir leben in unserem eigenen Land und in
unserem eigenen Haus in Angst Morgen
können Sie mir verbieten zu arbeiten
heute können Sie es tun ich fühle mich
wie in einem Gefängnis
auch layla und die anderen Frauen sind
mutig so offen Kritik zu üben eines
wollen sie sich nicht nehmen lassen ihre
Stimme
ja jetzt der Sport Rudi ja mit einem
traditionellen Radrennen zunächst nach
204 Kilometern hat der dänische Radprofi
Sören grau Andersen die 62 Ausgabe des
eintagesklassikers Eschborn Frankfurt
gewonnen als bester Deutscher erreichte
Georg Steinhauser am mai-feiertag Platz
in der vom Frühling begrüßten
Mainmetropole fiel der Startschuss kurz
nach 12 Uhr
rund 150 Fahrer machten sich auf den 204
km langen Weg durch den Taunus eine
Ausreißergruppe von sechs Fahrern konnte
sich bald schon absetzen wurde aber beim
zweiten Anstieg auf den Feldberg vom
Hauptfeld wieder geschluckt den
Zielsprint vor der Alten Oper in
Frankfurt macht eine zehnköpfige
Ausreißergruppe dann unter sich aus es
gewann der Dennis Sören grau Andersen
vor dem Österreicher Patrick Konrad und
Alessandro für daily aus Italien
Jürgen Klopp ist der Qualifikation für
einen europäischen Wettbewerb wieder
ganz nahe gekommen nach dem 4:3
Siegtreffer gegen die Tottenham Hotspurs
zeigte sich aber auch unter welchem
Druck der Trainer des FC Liverpool stand
wütend Klopp auf den vierten Offiziellen
los die Schiedsrichterleistung passte
ihm gar nicht damit handelt es sich eine
Oberschenkelzerrung und eventuell ein
Disziplinarverfahren ein dabei hatte es
nach Mose Allahs Treffer zum 13.09 nach
einem entspannten Sieg ausgesehen doch
dann muss Klopp miterleben wie Tabellen
Nachbar Tottenham Treffer und Treffer
aufholt und tatsächlich gleich Tottenham
in der dritten Minute der Nachspielzeit
durch Ritalin und zum 13.3 aus doch nur
98 Sekunden später schlägt Liverpool
durch junge Shooter zurück vier zu drei
eine Dramaturgie wie geschaffen für ein
mentalitätsmonster
noch Tennis Jan Lennart Strumpf hat beim
ATP Masters Turnier in Madrid als
dritter deutscher Tennisspieler das
Achtelfinale erreicht der 33-Jährige
besiegte den Serben Duschan lajovic mit
zwei zu Einsätzen dabei überzeugte der
Davis cupspieler mit seinem druckvollen
Angriffsspiel vor Stoff waren bereits
Alexander Zverev und Daniel als Meier
ins Achtelfinale eingezogen
[Applaus]
wollte man noch sehen das war's genau
danke schön auch wenn die Temperaturen
noch nicht danach schreien am 1 Mai
beginnt traditionell die Freibadsaison
wie hier in Frankfurt am Main nutzten
einige die Gelegenheit um bei eher
frischen Temperaturen ihre Bahnen unter
freiem Himmel zu ziehen andere Freibäder
und andere schwimmfans warten mit dem
Start noch bis es längere Zeit richtig
warm wird
es wird kälter aber auch heller die
Sonne aus dem Nordwesten löst langsam
die Schauer und Gewitter im Süden und
Osten ab Details hat gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka um 9:45 Uhr wir wünschen Ihnen
einen schönen Abend noch und bis morgen
tschüss
[Musik]
willkommen im Mai von zwei Seiten wird
das Wetter bei uns spannend zum einen
mit diesem Tief über Italien das dort
Regen und in den Alpen auch Schnee
bringt und zum anderen mit diesem Hoch
von der Nordsee das hinter einer
Kaltfront trockenere und kühlere Luft
heranbringt die Kaltfront eines Tees das
wir gar nicht sehen das über
Skandinavien liegt überquert uns morgen
heute Nacht gibt es noch kräftige schaue
und Gewitter im Süden und über die
Nordhälfte ziehen etliche Regenschauer
hinweg bei Temperaturen von 10 bis 4
Grad und morgen gibt's dann viele
Schauer und Gewitter im Süden und auch
im Osten sie ziehen im Laufe des Tages
ostwärts ab dann wird es von Nordwesten
immer freundlicher Sonne und Wolken
wechseln sich ab bei Nordwestwind dort
ist es kühl dort liegen morgen die
Temperaturen nur so bei 10 11 Grad sonst
werden 12 bis 16 am Oberrhein bis 19
Grad erreicht am Mittwoch gibt's noch
letzte Schauer im Südosten danach wird
es freundlicher und am Freitag stürmisch
an der Ostsee genannt